[Music]
hi everyone i'm drew barrymore host of
well the drew barrymore show and welcome
to the drewbury moore show podcast we'll
be bringing the light and the laughter
from the full episodes of the show
straight to your ears
that's right we're streaming all the
good vibes you need to conquer your day
and see that glass half full or get that
cookie from the cookie jar or okay
that's not an expression but it's just
fun but we truly do cover it all to give
you an exhilarating journey each episode
yummy series like drew's cookbook club
ooh speaking of food where friends like
pilar valdez and i delved into cookbook
recommendations swap pro tips and make
special meals with you at home
one of the reasons why i love this pasta
is because it's super simple and it uses
buccatini pasta
it's like a spaghetti sexy cousin you
know it's like bouncy
and in true gooders we speak to
inspiring people doing things in their
community that are small big and
everything in between good deeds can't
go unrewarded of course so listen out
for some emotional surprises
this is crazy
meeting drew barrymore getting
computers for our school
in design by drew we find easy ways for
you to spruce up your decor to transform
your surroundings into the space of your
dreams this is very personal for me and
we reach out to friends like expert
mikhail welch
we were putting the design together so
drew said she wanted a storage out of it
love it
there's also drew's news where my
co-pilot ross matthews and i get to swap
stories that make us feel informed
optimistic and hopeful
if news were bagels we tried to be the
everything
and with me at the desk is my toasty
little sesame seed ross matthew
hi everybody
from a-listers to hometown heroes to
influencers stopping by with the latest
trends you never know who might bring us
some news you can use i'm like why are
we not friends by the way
ah i'm i'm in
i'm so weird
i'm into
shining a light on beauty and
inspiration in the world around us is
why we started the drew barrymore show
whenever and wherever you listen we hope
that you feel that warm connection
stream from the car the train the shower
wait what that doesn't work well you
never know whatever you're into
just take a moment to see the sunny side
of life with us
i can't wait to go on this journey
together hear the new episodes of the
drew barrymore show podcast every day
monday through friday listen on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcast
[Music]